انفجار في الألوان أنماط ونقاط لا تعد ولا تحصى
، المزيد من النقاط ،
كوكبة من النقاط ، هذه هي
أعمال yayoi kusama اليابانية التي يمكن
القول إنها أشهر فنانة حية في العالم
منذ سبعة عقود ، وقد
ابتكرت بكثافة عبر
وسائط متعددة من
لوحات القرع التي يمكن التعرف عليها على الفور والتي يمكنها التحكم
الملايين في مزاد علني لتذاكر
تركيبات غرفة المرايا الغامرة
التي تباع باستمرار
في المتاحف في جميع أنحاء العالم هنا في متحف M plus
في هونغ كونغ ، تم جمع أكثر من 200 من أعمالها
الفنية معًا
في أكبر معرض استعادي لأعمالها في
آسيا خارج اليابان
هناك  هي قطع مبكرة مثل هذا الرسم الذي
أنشأته kusama في سن 16 عامًا وأكملت الأعمال
هذا العام فقط هذا
التركيب الواسع النطاق بتكليف
من المتحف وهو إعادة تخيل من Technicolor
لعملها في عام 1976 لموت العصب الذي تم
ترتيبه زمنياً وموضوعياً ،
حيث يقدم العرض نظرة
ثاقبة للأفكار التي
استكشف الفنان باستمرار بما في ذلك الأفكار
اللانهاية التي حفزتها الهلاوس في مرحلة الطفولة ،
الشيء اللافت للنظر حول
مهنة كوساما هو
إعادة النظر في هذه الأفكار الخارقة وإعادة
تفسيرها مرارًا وتكرارًا ،
وتستمر هذه الأشكال في التطور لأن
جميعها تأتي من أساس قوي
جدًا لهذه الأفكار العميقة حول
الإنسانية وارتباطها.  إلى الطبيعة
في الكون ولكن أيضًا فكرة
الحياة والموت كأوجه
تكامل مع بعضها البعض في 93
kusama لا تزال تعمل في الوقت الحاضر من
غرفتها في مستشفى للأمراض النفسية حيث
تعيش طواعية منذ
أواخر السبعينيات ، فأنت تعلم أن عليها أن ترسم
كل يوم  إنه مصدر للعلاج
والشفاء لأن فنها هو شكل من أشكال
البقاء على قيد الحياة بالنسبة لها وكلما كانت أكثر
حيوية وكلما جعلتها
أكثر قوة ،
فإن عملها له تيارات خفية مظلمة
تعكس معاركها مع
المرض العقلي ولكن هناك أيضًا فرح
وعميق  رغبتي في الاتصال
سأستمر في خلق
عالم مليء بالرهبة من الحياة قالت لشبكة CNN في مقابلة قصيرة
عبر البريد الإلكتروني  مضيفة أنها
أرادت احتضان جميع رسائل الحب
والسلام والكون
في عصر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
وقد وجد فن kusama جماهير أوسع للعديد من
الزائرين ، ومن أبرز ما
يميز هذا الفضاء الغامر النقاط المميزة لـ kusama في
كل مكان والمرايا المثبتة
تعطي هذا المنوم  وهم من الفضاء اللامتناهي
، يُنظر إلى متحف عالمي للثقافة المرئية
والإضافية منذ فترة طويلة على أنه رد آسيا
على شريط لندن الحديث أو متحف الفن الحديث في نيويورك ،
ولكن عندما تم افتتاحه أخيرًا في أواخر عام
2021 بعد عقد من الزمن في جعله
يواجه عددًا من
التحديات السياسية المتغيرة  البيئة التي
لا تزال تثير مخاوف الرقابة
عبر مختلف القطاعات بما في ذلك الفن
وقواعد الوباء الصارمة في هونغ كونغ التي
منعت معظم السياح من القدوم
إلى المدينة وأغلقت المتحف لمدة
ثلاثة أشهر ولكن كان هناك بعض
Silver Linings بالإضافة إلى أنه تم بالفعل
إحصاء أكثر من 2 مليون زائر  تقريبًا
جميع سكان هونغ كونغ
سيفتحون متحفًا عالميًا ويحتضنهم
المحليون  الجمهور أولاً وقبل كل شيء في
عامه الأول لا يمكن أن يكون طريقة أفضل
لبدء المتحف
الآن مع قيود سهلة
يأمل القيمون على M plus أن يتدفق المزيد من
الزوار الدوليين من خلال
أبوابه في العام الجديد لمشاهدة مجموعته الضخمة
وتجربة معرض Kosama
شخصيًا الذي يمتد خلال شهر مايو ،
ما الذي تأمل أن يبتعد الزوار
عنه بعد تجربة هذا المعرض
أن
كوساما هي أكثر بكثير من
منحوتات اليقطين وأنماط منقطة لدرجة
أنها مفكرة في الفلسفة العميقة
كشخصية رائدة كشفت حقًا
الكثير عنها  نفسها هي
ضعفها الذي تكافح به
كمصدر إلهام لفنها
كوسيلة للشفاء والتواصل
دليل حي على أن الفن هو العلاج كريستي
شهوة CNN هونج كونج
[موسيقى]